reviewed gravity rush to that happened I
even playing that for what like a week
or two now yeah put it in like about 25
hours and you give it a 9 you'd like it
a lot yeah I really did what's uh I mean
we'll dive into like that specifically I
didn't play much I didn't play much
gravity rush one I was gonna try out I
still haven't gotten the chance to play
to yet so I have a lot of questions for
you Jake I know you played the first one
but yeah like hit us with it what's the
overarching like what did you enjoy
about this game so much well you gotta
keep in mind that I definitely like
played a lot of the first game like I
ended up reviewing the remaster so I had
that context going in which ended up
being pretty important to just my
personal experience because you know
like this game the first game definitely
nailed delivering like a very
unconventional sense of movement like
games play with flight and gravity all
the time but none really mixed them the
way the gravity rush did the rest of the
game around that was kind of lacking so
one of the things that really surprised
me that I loved about gravity rush too
is that it you know the same mechanics
returned they built upon those but more
importantly the world is just far more
dense and just bigger in general like
huge and so yes scale is one thing and
like that's great
but then also I felt like I was able to
get a lot more out of the world just by
simply exploring it in side quests they
weren't always the best objectives to
chase but they did offer nice
interesting narratives so you know it's
just like an all-around like a really
really just great game and even if you
just took it as a superficial level the
graphics and the soundtrack are are just
amazing yeah it's gorgeous like a cell
shading on the character at least is
that kind of true for the little bit
yeah kinda yeah it is just this sort of
like cartoonish render and it definitely
fits the game because it's presented you
say episodic that brings to mind certain
aspects of episodic games but really
it's just this game is broken up into
quote-unquote episodes and and through
that and with the the visual you know
style it kind of feels like you're
playing an anime like it does feel like
you are an anime superhero and you
finish it an entire season yeah
which is pretty cool cool yeah I mean
like while you were touching on it you
said like the obviously you see a lot of
series go kind of open world whereas you
know that their predecessors might not
be might be a little more linear
you did feel that overall the structure
of this game in terms of being open
world and explore well I think you
mentioned your review that like
obviously half the joy this game just
comes from moving around this over the
world yeah and like the first game
definitely had the same sensibilities it
just didn't have the scope to really you
know match what people think of when
they think of open-world right I mean it
was really just one location with a few
secondary places that were detached in
the original game so yeah in this one
you definitely get you know a better
sense that you're part of a larger
society and it really helps that all the
people and you know things happening in
the world like sort of fill in that
picture as well because it's it's not
like just a couple of PCs here and there
it's a lot of NPCs and they're all going
about their own business there's a lot
like air traffic like air vehicles and
stuff so just in terms of being an
open-world it feels you know fully
realized at this stage you're a fan of
stories and video games I like them
how's this one it is good it again I
think because I experienced the first
game which left a lot of unanswered
questions I found the story in this game
to be super valuable there is like a new
tale that is told that is sort of about
okay there's a society where there's
rich people and poor people and they
struggle to kind of get along like okay
that age-old tale and that that is okay
like there's enough character in there
to feel like it's enjoyable but the huge
payoff is how the game addresses things
from the past even going you know prior
to the original game acting as a prequel
as much as it is a sequel in some ways
super fulfilling you know I don't have
as many unanswered questions as time and
any that I do have it's intentional like
it seems like it's made on purpose where
people be better off playing the first
game first in order to fully enjoy the
second game mmm that's a tough question
the first game is good but like if I had
to I mean I would say play this game
first I think you'll get a lot out of it
anyway mm-hmm yeah because at least
mechanically this game is theirs it's
more diverse so it it's more rewarding
just to play a story aside the story bit
is what kind of complicates that answer
yeah there's like separate movement
style she gets right the lunar and the
Jupiter Jupiter right so or ones like we
have an type even more anti-gravity well
so I mean like her special ability
normally you're basically saying okay
this
gravity works like this now and then you
end up basically deciding which way is
down right so you fall where you want to
but you end up using like a gravity
power quote unquote in the lunar style
you just equip armor and you can still
trigger your gravity ability but you're
also just made lighter without
activating that ability so you can do
things like jump really far and high
which makes exploration feel a little
bit different because you don't have to
careen through a city or walk on the
ground you can like literally jump over
buildings which is different than flying
and then in battle there's you know some
things that lunar adds Jupiter makes you
sort of like a tank you fall a lot
faster but you hit a lot harder so it's
sort of the antithesis to the lunar
style and they said the boss battles are
pretty badass in this game right yes the
the combat is sort of very similar
between enemies and big bosses like
you're doing the same basic things but
the presentation and the scale of the
boss fights are what are really
impressive there's one I didn't capture
footage of it it turns out but if you've
ever seen a Keira and you know the final
scene of that movie I've I can't think
of any other images but this game
doesn't homage to that better than I can
imagine any other thing doing it it's
really cool what does cats deal what's
her deal like what's the premise of
these for people who don't know in a
nutshell what's what's the premise of
these games well so the the premise in
the original game was that cat didn't
know who she was she woke up in a city
she had amnesia do any of us right I
don't know I asked myself that every day
and I never have a good sorry I
interrupted yeah so that last game there
was you know sort of some political
stuff going on in the society she lived
in and there was this guy named alias he
was kind of egging her on and also kind
of helping things he didn't know who she
was he didn't who alias was so in this
game that story is addressed but
initially what the deal is is like at
the end of the second game you didn't
see it but in the interim there was a
gravity storm you were swept up and you
lost your powers and you ended up in
this like slave camp basically and you
have to kind of fight your way out of
that or in the trust of the leader and
you realize okay she's a pretty good
person and you have to basically stop
the rich from corrupting government in
this this new location
and it builds from the airbag I can't
spoiling well one thing that sounds
you've been waiting to we need a just
show on gamespot dedicated to you
describing these outlandish blogs as if
you're describing like your commute to
work and I got on the bus to like get
all these details through the driver
almost crashed it was raining yeah
there's a gravity storm while you were
in a coma yeah you know it's like that
typical that's like the zombie
apocalypse trope while you're like the
what is it um twenty-eight days later
and then Walking Dead did it as well no
this time it's a gravity storm you wake
up and it's not zombies it's floating
oxygen no one understands gravity don't
get me if you don't have her powers I
feel like that city would be a nightmare
to live in yes yeah how did normal
people get around stuck on their little
spot because it's all islands everything
is like broken up in islands but they do
have those little airships one of the
really fun things to do in this game it
because you have these gravity powers so
you can like also pick up things that
are around you it's sort of what you
create like a Stacia stasis shield or
something like that yeah and you can
just go into the middle of a market and
just activate that thing and people and
objects and stalls and businesses just
like fly up in the air and you can like
throw them into other things and people
just kind of pick themselves up and dust
themselves off and keep going yeah it's
the game is you know it deals with some
heavy handed stuff but like I said my
review like there's a silver lining to
everything sometimes that's humor it
doesn't really try to be real in all
respects just going through your footage
cuz I edited yeah just going through
your footage like there was like stuff
of you flying through and there's just a
guy stuck behind you like ya know so
better those are some the side quests
it's more or less an escort mission but
the challenge is not escorting the
person the challenge is bringing them to
the point in town that they want to be
in and just knowing what they're
referring to but yeah like he's like an
uber you pick up an NPC you're like
alright we're going and they just
literally like float in and out of frame
oh we're going we don't need right
so Don learner's slow shot you got just
a pan and it looks like cats flying
looks all cool for like a while right
lowly pans run this guy just screaming
I'm glad you got that because I
definitely meant to capture that does
not take itself too seriously no it
doesn't it doesn't get it yeah the
little side missions will take a topic
seriously for a moment but then it'll
kind of bring it around to this hyper
positive optimistic thing but overall
you gave it a glowing review of people
should play yes I think I really think
people should it's super unusual it
definitely takes a lot of getting used
to but it is it is a very fascinating
experience and and just joyful
throughout cool so yeah that is the
gravity rush to review Peter Brown gave
it a 9 out of 10 that will be on that is
up on gamespot calm now if you want to
read the whole thing we have a video
review as well should be on youtube or
if you're watching this if you're
listening to this on itunes you can go
check that out at GameSpot calm and let
us know what you think about the game
once you get the chance to play it or
let us know if you plan on picking it up
in the comments below
[Music]